e a cada minuto cinco empresas nascem e
a cada cinco uma morre
tá bom eu vim hoje aqui falar para vocês
as três fases da jornada empreendedora
da ideia seja quando você tem uma ideia
até o momento em que você tem uma
empresa nas suas mãos vão trabalho que
nós fizemos de muito aprendizado muita
pesquisa e principalmente baseado em
mais de mil horas de mentoria
e eu trago aqui um conceito complexo mas
assim um certo que de indignação e o meu
compromisso hoje aqui é com a verdade né
a minha verdade e aquilo que eu
vivenciei na pele e eu acredito que
muitos de vocês aqui ou queiram
empreender ou seja empreendedores mas eu
tô com uma certa raiva raiva porque
porque eu entro nas redes sociais e o
que que eu vejo que empreender é super
tranquilo você vai trabalhar menos e vai
ganhar mais isso me causa um desconforto
muito grande e é isso que eu vim fazer
aqui contar para vocês em três fases
como essa jornada como é a nossa visão
sobre essa jornada
é bom e antes eu queria falar que a cada
três pessoas jovens em especial o estudo
da firjan duas querem aprender isso
tenha acontecido basicamente por alguns
fatores o primeiro tecnologia hoje
qualquer pessoa de qualquer lugar
conectado consegue montar um negócio
forma muito simples o segundo é a
conexão a poucos cliques vocês aqui
podem se conectar com qualquer pessoa no
mundo com valores e potenciais
semelhantes
oi e a economia ciclos de retração
expansão da economia fazem com que a
gente começa a enxergar empreendedorismo
como uma alternativa e o último é a
imagem do empreendedor quem é que nunca
se deparou com frases motivacionais em
redes sociais dizendo que o empreendedor
é um grande herói que ele vai salvar o
mundo às vezes dá um certo cansaço né e
aí a gente vai entender um pouco melhor
a mente dessas pessoas e a gente se
deparou com isso pessoas que né meios
neve sejam pessoas nas redes sociais ou
meios né super sérios jornalisticos
falando sobre isso que empreender é ter
liberdade é trabalhar menos e ganhar
mais mais qualidade de vida mais férias
e aí a gente dividiu isso em três
grandes fases essa jornada que eu chamo
de três peixe eu vou começar com o
primeiro pedro
é paixão paixão é um momento em que você
tem a ideia você se apaixona por ela
ardentemente você acredita que ela uma
ideia de um bilhão de dólares beleza a
gente divide esse grupo apaixonado que
ainda não é um empreendedor em dois
grupos o primeiro grupo ele é um grupo
que eu digo que ele é bastante curioso
ele vai ele tem uma ideia ele divide com
os amigos compartilha começa a fazer e
aí ele começa a pensar um eu não tenho
dinheiro um eu não tenho um escritório
eu não tenho sócio e eu não não não
tempo todo parece que ele tá esperando a
conjuntura dos astros celestiais saturno
na casa 12 né então tem toda uma questão
ali para que as coisas aconteçam ou seja
ele não se vê como a gente desse
processo que cria as condições ideais
paris para isso tudo acontecer
oi e ele entra no que eu chamo de ciclo
da procrastinação e acreditando que eu
tô falando muitas pessoas passam a vida
inteira esse ciclo o segundo grupo ele
não para ele quer seguir em um grupo
dois ele quebra esse ciclo e como é que
ele quebra ele fala eu tenho uma ideia
eu compartilho e eu não divido só comigo
eu compartilhe com outras pessoas e mais
do que isso eu vou lá eu pego o que eu
tenho na minha mão e eu faço aqui agora
com os recursos que eu tenho eu criei
essas condições só manda isso eles tem
um propósito muito grande um propósito
que vai além do simplesmente querer ter
um negócio para aparecer na capa da ford
ele tá ali o que ele realmente quer
fazer um negócio acontecer e aí ele
segue e ele vai pôr segundo p que é o
que eu chamo de problema e é nesse
momento que todas essas ideias lindas e
maravilhosas que ele tinha
e por terra por quê porque ele começa
levar não infinitos nãos não de
fornecedor não de pessoas que achavam a
ideia maravilhosa que simplesmente
pararem falaram olha não sei se eu vou
comprar não sei se faz tanto sentido
assim para mim quem nunca né a prática é
muito diferente de quando você idealiza
é meio óbvio mas muita gente esquece
disso e aí é o que eu chamo de
cotovelada no mercado é o mercado te
dando pancada de todos os lados e aí
você precisa começar a desenvolver
algumas habilidades muito importante
vendas eu escuto alguns empregadores de
primeira viagem falando assim ai mas eu
não gosto de vender e aí eu falo para
eles como você espera trazer receita
para o seu negócio
se você não tem funcionários não tem
ninguém você a empresa nesse momento
então eu digo vendas é um motor de
qualquer negócio não importa qual seja
então essa é uma habilidade que por mais
difícil que seja a gente precisa
desenvolver cada um do seu jeito cada um
respeitando a sua individualidade mas é
muito importante sócios aqui eu quero
falar um ponto que é muito importante
sociedade é é uma das principais causas
de falência nas empresas porque porque
quando você inicia um negócio muitas
pessoas aí eu me simpatizei com essa
pessoa é bacana é legal eu gosto de
estar com ela
ah e não leva em consideração três
principais fatores o primeiro a ambição
a tua missão ela é semelhante à do outro
que que eu quero dizer com isso eu quero
construir uma padaria o outro que
construiu uma rede de padarias uma hora
essas visões vão colidir propósito qual
o propósito que eu tenho nesse negócio
ele é semelhante e o outro que é muito
importante que tem muita briga em
sociedade é o nível de sacrifício né ou
seja de priorização em relação à vida
com aquele negócio é dizer bom tudo bem
é a gente tem aqui um negócio eu tô
disposto a trabalhar sete dias por
semana e o outro tá disposto a trabalhar
três isso pode ser aqui causa um
problema e por último
é um problema real você sai lá da tua
apresentação né do da sua planilha e
você vai para a realidade todo negócio
tem que resolver um problema se a gente
está sentado em cadeiras se existe esse
projetor essa iluminação é porque ela
resolve um problema então negócio não
pode ser diferente disso e aí você
começar a realizar nesse momento que a
sua vida é bem diferente dos filmes que
você assistiu sobre empreendedores até
aquele momento que se dividem em três
momentos primeiro momento do filme os
primeiros 30 minutos é aquele momento
que ele tem a ideia e aí ele vai falando
com o mercado depois ele começa de
problemas mas 30 minutos e os 30 minutos
finais a escalada dele rumo ao sucesso
é bom nesse momento você fala bom acho
que disso aí 80 minutos é só pancadaria
quem sabe alguma coisa diferente alguém
que já se afogou
e aí tá vivo claro
e eu já e é desesperador eu digo que
essa fase é a fase do afogamento é o
momento que você não tem chão você não
tem chão e você tá nadando você engole
um pouco de água volta e olha que eu sei
nadar e você começa a sentir cansaço e
aí você tem a brilhante ideia de boiar e
aí vem mais onda e você continua
engolindo água porque o marca revoltado
e aí você lembra que você aos 15 anos
teve aula de surf e não adiciona que o
professor disse para você sempre que
você entrar numa correnteza pegue uma
diagonal diagonal do que cê tá no meio
do mar 360° diagonal do que e aí eu falo
por que que eu não prestei atenção
naquele negócio com certeza tem um jeito
mas eu não fiz
bom e é nesse momento que a gente divide
em dois grupos o primeiro grupo é um
grupo que em geral começa a perceber
essa situação ele realiza que aquilo que
ele imaginava não é real todas aquelas
visões lindas e maravilhosas e a super
legítimo entender que isso aqui não é
para mim não é o que eu quero
oi e aí tem um outro grupo que segue ea
pergunta que fica é é resiliência ou
teimosia seguir nesse momento
tá bom eu costumo dizer que resiliência
é para quem tem sucesso teimosia é pra
quem pra casa e o grupo dois é um grupo
que a gente estudou bastante e chegamos
a algumas conclusões são pessoas que em
geral tem um certo prazer por esta
sensação do afogamento e da aventura de
ultrapassar desafios e principalmente
porque eles querem provar para si
próprios e para outros e esse é um dos
grandes problemas dos empreendedores e
causam um número muito grande de
depressão e é nesse momento que essas
pessoas se utilizam de três habilidades
muito bem calibrados a primeira delas é
a humildade humildade para aprender de
forma contínua ouvir as pessoas os seus
clientes os mentores outros
empreendedores de forma constante
adaptabilidade
e muito palming idade e é basicamente
você prestar atenção no movimento do
mercado se adaptar às mudanças do mundo
dos seus clientes e você replicar isso
no seu produto no seu serviço e por fim
consistência sem consistência nenhum dos
outros dois faz sentido consistência é
você traçar um plano e executar é uma
das habilidade mais difíceis que existem
hoje em dia foco porque as pessoas têm é
uma grande habilidade e com isso nós
vamos por último pé de processo
e é nesse momento que acontece a próxima
quebra de expectativa porque até então é
um para muitas pessoas aquela jornada
ainda né você se sente num processo no
fluxo mas chegou a terminar do momento
que você olha e fala eu não quero ficar
afogado para o resto da minha vida você
é que é na verdade ali no oceano mas não
belo barco né e aí você começa a ver que
tudo que você fez até aquele momento não
está surtindo o resultado porque ninguém
quer trabalhar muito mais do que
trabalhava e ganhando menos né não faz
sentido isso numa lógica racional
eu ia nesse momento que existe uma outra
quebra de paradigma entre os ser
empreendedor e o ser empresário o ser
empreendedor você pode ser empreendedor
onde você quiser uma empresa no setor
público sendo médico nascendo um
advogado porque porque é um conjunto de
competências que nos guia é você ser uma
pessoa que executa uma pessoa que
consegue ser inovador e consegue
resolver problemas tem milhões de outras
competências mas de forma resumida aqui
para gente
e esse empresário na verdade é você ter
uma empresa seja um organismo vivo com
pessoas que trabalham dentro de uma
direção um rumo com uma visão e
principalmente sendo auto-gerenciável ou
seja uma empresa deveria nem ligar para
sua existência e aí nós vamos perguntar
para esses empreendedores qual era o
sonho deles
o que eles sonham com ter realmente uma
empresa o organismo autónomo né todo
mundo sonha né a grande maioria deles
sonha em ter um organismo que funcione
que ele possa estar junto crescer se
desenvolver né que ele seja grande porém
não necessariamente gigante que o grande
ele é um valor muito relativo acho que
ele seja algo que contemple os sonhos
dele mas eles sonham com uma empresa
oi e o quê que e o que que a gente viu
né que para eles chegarem a esse sonho
eles precisam de fato superar desafios e
quando a gente perguntou para eles que
desafios eram esses essa foi a resposta
desafios da ordem de crescimento vendas
existe uma solidão muito grande em sem
empreendedor uma solidão realmente que
você se você não tiver inserido numa
comunidade isso faz com que você tenha
grandes questões equipe gestão esses são
os grandes desafios e aí com isso a
gente analisou essas empresas esses
empreendedores e vimos que basicamente
os que conseguem ir para o próximo nível
eles tem propósito não só o propósito
mas passar esse propósito para um grupo
de pessoas que estão com ele todos os
dias uma visão é uma visão
as pessoas trabalhando engajados numa
direção mas para isso é preciso planejar
você precisa ter um caminho para chegar
nessa visão mas eu costumo dizer uma
frase que eu gosto muito de bruce lee
que é seja a água eu não é que aquele
planejamento precisa ser uma pedra né
não ele precisa ser flexível com o
mercado ele precisa dançar com o mercado
a visão holística eu escuto algumas
pessoas dizendo nossa eu adoro market
grande maioria dos empreendedores adora
marketing é muito raro alguém que fala
eu amo finanças na ninguém gosta mas é
fundamental é fundamental porque tem
empresas que quebram sem nem saber o
porquê quebraram por uma péssima gestão
de fluxo de caixa então empreendedor
precisa ter uma visão holística e o
preto priorizar priorizar é fundamental
é você pegar vinte por cento dos
problemas que você tem
o que resolvidos geram impacto e
resultado por oitenta por cento dessas
coisas bom e o mais importante é clichê
mas é muito importante a gente gente não
aqui como colaboradores mas eu digo
pessoas que fazem a diferença e o
conselho que eu tenho para dar para
vocês é se afastem das pessoas que não
te motivam que não acreditam em você e
se aproxime daquelas que acreditam eu
tenho muita sorte de ter do meu lado paz
e um esposo incrível que sempre que eu
tô mal e que eu não sei o que fazer ele
sempre tá do meu lado e ele sempre me dá
a mão e ele acredita em mim e não
confundam acreditar com passar a mão na
cabeça na verdade não é isso é às vezes
muitas vezes ser durão e dizer cara vai
por esse caminho e é isso que a gente
precisa então
a compaixão não acredite só na sua ideia
ela não é suficiente resolva os
problemas usando humildade
adaptabilidade e consistência e processo
pessoas juntas trabalhando numa direção
sabendo e dividindo o seu propósito com
elas
oi e o finn é essa jornada não acabou e
nem vai acabar nunca porque o mundo muda
a empresa é um organismo vivo e é uma
jornada interminável o que eu posso
dizer é se depois de tudo que você ouviu
você quer continuar empreendendo ou de
alguma forma quer empreender eu posso
dizer para você nunca parar nunca pare
seja invencível impossível em pável
obrigada a